welcome to show friends neighbors
kinsmen who hope you've had a satisfying
Friday so far we had a little scare this
morning tornado warning in our neck of
the woods
another consequence of climate change no
doubt so went to the basement and I was
with my wife and kids and if you think
that I had to comfort my terrified
children about the tornado you don't
know my children they were absolutely
ecstatic about the entire thing they
apparently seem to think that the
tornado would suck us up and bring us to
Oz to meet the munchkins and I didn't
have the heart to tell them that if it
hits our house we ain't going to Oz to
put it mildly but I was brought back in
my mind to the time when I was about
their age and we had flooding on our
street where we lived and I couldn't
understand why my parents were so
distressed about it because I kept
thinking will a flood you know it's
gonna the flood will come into our house
I'll turn our whole house into a pool
there will be like a water slide down
the steps it's gonna be so exciting and
I just couldn't I didn't understand
their lack of enthusiasm but now now I
think I know I think I get it
alright well Pete Budaj may or may not
have won Iowa the AAP announced
yesterday that they can't announce a
winner because they don't know the whole
process is so messed up it's too close
to call and screw it basically the
paraphrase that was the what they said
either way the the significance of Iowa
is less about the delicate delegates and
more about the momentum and the media
coverage heading into the rest of the
primaries New Hampshire and so on
so whether Buddha judge won or not he's
been robbed of that benefit which i
think is great it could not have
happened to a more deserving person
Buddha judges I think perhaps the most
formidable politician left in the field
simply because he's not a communist or
he's not an out-and-out communist he's
not known as a communist and he's also
not 900 87 years old and so that those
two factors alone I think make him the
most formidable but that's not a
compliment really certainly not a
compliment of his character because
character wise he may well
be the worst of the bunch and I want to
show you another example that Buddha did
yesterday was was given the opportunity
to come out at least against infanticide
that is the killing of fully developed
infants outside of the womb he was given
the opportunity to at least say he's
against that and he declined so you
really need to hear this audio and I'm
gonna play it for you in in just in just
a moment but first a word from policy
genius you know the future is is
unknowable it's the thing about the
future you never know what's going to
happen and that's why the only thing we
can do you know you can't be paranoid as
maybe I can sometimes tend to be there's
no need for that just be prepared be
prepared for whatever might happen and
make sure you're protecting yourself and
the people that you love the most and
the year 2020 shows up you know a lot in
science fiction a lot of people
predicted that by now we'd be
teleporting to work or living on Mars
and you know at least having a
hovercraft I was hoping at least for
Harvick cause I figured at least by now
we'd have that but we don't even have
that a lot of those predictions were
wrong the truth is we're always going to
get the future wrong which is why we
need to get life insurance right now and
that's where policy genius can help once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork all the red
tape so you don't have to worry about
that sometimes it can be very daunting
task to take on something like life
insurance you're not sure exactly where
to go with it well policy genius is
gonna make it easy for you and not just
life insurance by the way they've also
you know home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance again this is all
about solve up getting ready for the
future being ready for the future
whatever might happen and protecting
yourself protecting your family and so
not just life insurance but home
insurance auto insurance all that stuff
and that's why you need policy genius so
if your science-fiction dreams for
twenty twenty twenty twenty twenty still
haven't become science fact don't get
discouraged get life insurance instead
it takes just a few minutes to find your
price and apply at policy genius.com
policy genius will always get the future
wrong better get life insurance right
okay so here's megan mccain with pete
Budaj and megan here first of all
subjects buddha judge too
exactly the line of questioning that
every Democrat should be subjected to so
I want you to watch this pay attention
to Buddha judges answers or non answers
but also to Megan showing exactly the
sort of questions that these people
ought to be asked and so rarely are so
here it is what's this if this is a
late-term situation then by definition
it's one where a woman was expecting to
carry the pregnancy to term then she
gets the most perhaps devastating news
of her life talk about families that
that may have picked out a name may be
assembling a crib and they learn
something excruciating and are faced
with this terrible choice and I don't
know what to tell them morally about
what they should do I just know that I
trust her in her decision medically or
morally isn't gonna be any better
because the government is commanding her
to do it in this is gonna hurt you in
the middle of the country with the
Republicans you're trying to win over
people like me this is a hard line and
quite frankly that question that answer
is just pretty bright it's just as
radical as I thought it was
sorry now it was it was no doubt made
more difficult by the clapping seals in
the audience but the only additional
thing I would have liked to hear Meghan
McCain see her do it really is bear down
on a firm hypothetical so a baby eight
months gestation physically healthy all
of its limbs and everything intact no
health problems should it be legal to
kill that person or not that's that's
IIIi would love to see the question
phrased exactly like that to these
people and so the question was not quite
as pointed as that but it doesn't matter
because we know his answer based on what
he said there he did give an answer to
that question effectively he's not
willing to entertain any limits on
abortion whatsoever of any kind he was
given the chance to draw some kind of
line any line draw a line at least
disqualifying partial-birth abortion and
infanticide and he wouldn't do that
partial-birth abortion which now within
fantasizing oh well no one not that that
no one does that that's not happening
okay well if nobody does it and it's not
happening it should be really easy for
you to say it shouldn't happen it should
be very if it's a if it's a non-existent
thing should be very easy to say I'm
against it right partial birth abortion
which by the way involves the killing of
fully developed infant humans as they
are emerging from the birth canal so
this is infanticide these are infants
that are partially out of the birth
canal already they are in the process of
being born and they're killed with an
incision in the back of the skull and
then a tube is inserted into that
incision and their brains are sucked out
of their heads while they're still alive
that's that's how it works and and that
quote procedure has been done in this
country thousands of times actually
that's what she was asking about and
Buddha judge wouldn't even come out
against that now by the way what as we
talked about yesterday the dot this
dodge of well no woman would choose this
unless there's a serious medical problem
that dodge is nonsense it's not true
it's a lie it's it did you can look up
the figures yourself look up the figures
in pro-abortion
sources if you want you know go to the
Guttmacher Institute or you look at
pro-abortion sources and and and see
what how they describe it even there
you'll find that with late term
abortions and late in very late term
abortions as well they can happen for
reasons that have nothing at all to do
with dire medical conditions that's a
fact and which is why what you'll find
when when the pro bortion side talks
about abortions for health reasons or
abortions for the health of the mother
when they talk about that for the health
of the mother and then you really get
into defining what they mean by that
what do you mean by health
well what they mean is physical health
yes
which again there has never been and
could never be an abortion conducted in
order to protect the physical health of
the mother so that doesn't that's that's
a that's a non-existent category but
physical health but they also mean
emotional health psychological health
spiritual health financial health all of
that is put into it and a great many of
these late from abortions five thousand
every single year are done for not for
physical health reasons but financial
health emotional health that sort of
thing okay but putting that aside
whatever the reason for this quote
procedure it is obviously always and in
every case immoral to suck the brains of
an out of an infant's head that's not
something I should have to say but I do
there is no scenario that could ever
make that anything less than one of the
most barbaric things you could ever do I
mean if you want to talk about the most
barbaric and wicked things a single
human can do to another single human I
think this is at the very very close to
the top of that list if not at the very
top we are now in the realm morally of
of things like child rape and
cannibalism okay we we've now we've now
made it up there or I should say down
there to that level the worst things
imaginable you have to put partial-birth
abortion into that category and even
this Buddha judge won't condemn he's a
coward
a liar a fraud a sad pathetic little man
that's what he is
III know he likes to present himself
like some sort of war hero but he is a
coward if you won't come out and at
least say no we should not be stabbing
infants in the skull and deeb reining
them while they're still alive if you
cannot even say that if you're not
willing to even say that then you are
the lowest most contemptible
sort of person and that's buddha jigeon
not just him that's all the rest of them
too in the Democratic field because you
would get the same answer from all the
rest of them my point here though is if
he has the reputation of being one of
the more reasonable ones or one of the
more moderate ones or one of the at
least he's got good character or
something no no okay let's play some
more audio for you this is AOC at some
sort of hearing yesterday being very
literal as she tends to be Miss
Hutchinson I wanna thank you about
bringing up the poverty draft and this
idea of a bootstrap you know this idea
and this metaphor of a bootstrap started
off as a joke because it's a physical
impossibility to lift yourself up by a
bootstrap by your shoelaces it's
physically impossible the whole thing is
a joke shoot for the stars that's
scientifically impossible we don't have
the technology the nearest stars for
light-years away that's 24 trillion
miles we've never made it there in time
this is this whole thing is a joke which
actually I have to admit when I see
those inspirational posters like every
every guidance counselor's office and at
every school in America has one that
says shoot for the moon even if you miss
you'll be among the stars that one does
kind of annoy me because I understand
that it's a metaphor but really if you
shoot for the moon and miss you're just
going to be floating in the vacuum of
space you're not gonna be anywhere in
here
the closes start because it star to be
the Sun which is millions and millions
of miles away and if we're talking about
interstellar travel then you're
trillions and trillions of miles away
from the nearest star so if you shoot
for the moon you damn well better hit it
otherwise you're going to die in the
black abyss of space but anyway that is
that is being overly literal which is
what aoc seems to be doing here who
doesn't understand the concept of
metaphors and that's the that's what
that college education I suppose gets
you the greater point though is the sort
of anti inspirational message
from AOC and her ilk she's saying not
just that pulling yourself up by the
bootstraps is physically impossible
which she's right about but that's not
really the point she's also saying that
a person trying to get ahead in life on
their own without the government may as
well be defying the laws of physics
because that's how impossible it is but
think about who this is coming from this
is coming from a woman who is today one
of the most influential and powerful
members of Congress god help us and yet
just a few years ago was a bartender
she went from bartender to congresswoman
okay she she actually is an example of
pulling yourself up by the bootstraps
and credit to her for that I respect
that aspect of her story now you know
she she's college-educated she's had a
lot of privileges in life it seems like
but even so to go from being a bartender
to being in Congress that's quite an
achievement and I give her credit for
that but it it's hard for me to give her
credit for that because then she gets
there to this successful point and she
turns around and tells other people they
can't do it and that's what I hate about
these these these socialists the ones on
the national stage because they're all
successful they've made something of
themselves to their credit they've used
the free market system they've used our
freedoms to their advantage fine good
for them and yet now they turn around
and say to everybody else you can't do
it it's impossible
rather than using themselves as an
example and saying no you can do it this
is this is this is very possible to do
doesn't mean that you're not going to
need help yes every successful person
has had some kind of help but we still
live in a country where you are uniquely
able where someone is with where there
is the the unique ability to go from the
very bottom to the very top it's not
true for everybody we talked about this
couple weeks ago that
we don't want to overplay that hand and
act like everybody who's at the bottom
could easily go up to the top it's not
easy number one and and and there can be
circumstances that make it basically
impossible so that is so that's true but
to take this position which a OC is
taken and the other socialists that
climbing the ladder is impossible in
principle that's some sort of myth even
while they themselves have done it is is
pretty shameful okay
speaking of college education David Hogg
you remember him is in Harvard now and
it's been really quite fascinating to
watch this kid get brainwashed in real
time and disturbing also fascinating now
he went into college a liberal clearly
but we can see the university system
taking his mind his susceptible mind and
molding it and shaping it and deforming
it and miss shaping it we could see this
happening so for example he tweeted a
couple of days ago this tweet that went
kind of viral it says a majority of the
people that live in the United States
are the descendants of illegal
colonizers that committed a mass
genocide now this is of course exactly
the kind of thing that kids learn in
college today and I saw someone on
Twitter say that this is exactly what
parents worry that when their kids come
home from college they're gonna come
home saying stuff like this this is this
is basically every parent's nightmare
that their kids are going to go to
college and come back saying crap like
this and and that's what's happened with
with him so but it is what kids learn in
college it's exactly what do you expect
a Harvard student to start saying in his
first year and so hog has fulfilled that
stereotype rather beautifully
the problem though of course is that
it's nonsense first of all European
settlers may have been colonizers they
may have been unwelcome colonizers they
may have been disliked colonizers you
could say that their colonization was
unfortunate
if
want you could describe it any of those
ways that's if that's your opinion
but what you can't say is that it was
illegal that would be an incorrect
statement that's not just an opinion
that's incorrect
they weren't the word illegal means
something they weren't illegal because
the United States at the time was not a
country so this goes for all the people
that say our ancestors were illegal
immigrants everybody is any any white
American as the is the descendant of
illegal immigrants that's not true
that's that's simply not true America at
the time North America was a landmass
very sparsely populated by a collection
of disconnected tribes very sparsely
populated you think right now in the
United States we've got 330 million
people
not counting the illegals the actual
illegals so we got 330 million give or
take in the United States back before
this this land was settled by the
Europeans there were across the entire
North American continent there were a
few million spread out all across those
millions of square miles okay so that's
what it was the call to me legal makes
no sense
it's inaccurate in illegal implies that
there were laws being broken and laws
being broken requires some sort of
central government of some kind making
those laws which there wasn't now if if
you come into United States now without
going through our standard immigration
process you're coming in illegally
because you're breaking our laws that
are in place if you do that in Mexico
you're going into Mexico illegally
because that they they have laws in
place China
same thing all of these established
countries if you go into those countries
and settle there without going through
the established process you're breaking
their laws here's my question the
colonizers that came here the European
settlers what law were they breaking
that's all you have to answer if you say
what they were there were illegal
immigrants okay
what law were they breaking show me the
law pull out whatever law book wasn't
was in and and showed show me that the
chapter and verse I could do that with
our immigration laws today this the
entire North American land mass was not
owned collectively by these tribes and
in fact the the idea that as the world
population grows and technology develops
that what the entire North American
content we would just leave alone nobody
would come here leave it to the two or
three million people living there no one
else gets to come doesn't make any sense
and the second point of course is that
when you say a majority of people in the
United States are descendants of illegal
colonizers committed mass genocide and
so on leaving aside the fact that the
word illegal doesn't make any sense here
the general sentiment that he's trying
to express would apply to pretty much
everybody on earth pretty much everybody
in the entire world and and this is
something that I'm always trying to
explain especially to those on the Left
who don't seem to understand it that the
Europeans were not unique in colonizing
they were not unique in building empires
they were not unique in slavery not by a
long shot
not none of that was unique empires
across the world function that way and
anywhere in the world where you go where
there are lines drawn this country that
country there's a line that line has
been fought over and not it we're not
talking pillow fights so all of the
settled land pretty much across the
entire world the people living there now
if you were to trace their lineage back
you're gonna find that they probably
quote stole it from somebody at some
point you're the descendant of someone
who moved into an area and killed people
and took over because that's the way the
world was settled everywhere not just
here
now the the responses you often hear to
that number one the first response is
that might be true but that's not might
be it is true that might be true but
that doesn't that's no excuse for the
Europeans yeah it's not an excuse but
that does mean that if we're having
conversations about ancestral sins if
we're having conversations about the
terrible things that people did hundreds
of years ago
the conversation shouldn't solely and
only be be focused on white Europeans
that's what it means
yeah we can have that conversation we
could say wherever they did commit
genocide that was a terrible thing
wherever they did steal land it was a
bad they should have done that fine I
agreed once we've established that and I
think we have established it can we talk
about the rest of the world it's like if
we're discussing slavery slavery in
North America was a horrible disgraceful
evil of course and I think we've I think
I think we've pretty well established on
I think everyone agrees I've never met
anybody who would disagree with that and
if I did meet them I would assume that
they're psychotic but if we're if we're
gonna have slavery can we at some point
discuss the fact that it existed
everywhere else on the globe I mean if
we're gonna talk about the history of
slavery why would it why would that
discussion only be focused on this part
of the world where we live now and only
go back a few hundred years there is a
larger picture here a larger context
that we could look at and discuss I
think that's a reasonable thing for
someone to point out so that's the first
dodge the second dodge is to say yes of
course there was empire building across
the world of course there was slavery
across the world but the Europeans were
unique in their in the way that they
industrialized it especially slavery and
in the way that they travelled across
the entire world to far reaching corners
of the world and colonized even their
other other empires didn't do that
that's sort of basically true but what
do you think what what stop
say Genghis Khan from conquering more
land than he did was it ethical qualms
did he say I don't wanna go any further
than this this this is enough guys I
don't want to go and now no it's it was
logistical it was a matter of logistics
it's just they weren't he wasn't capable
of going further than he did wasn't
ethical qualms so if other empires in
history didn't didn't colonize to the
extent of the Europeans that it's not
because they it's not because they they
figured a let's let's let's calm down
fellows this this is enough wasn't
ethics that stopped them is just it was
it was the force of history that stopped
them there was a lack of ability that
stuff there was a lack of technology
that stopped them the Aztecs enslaving
all of their neighboring tribes
harvesting their neighboring tribes for
for human sacrifices coming in and
taking women and children ripping their
hearts out feasting on their limbs
rolling their DeLand bodies down the
temple down the steps of the temple in
these in these barbaric satanic
ceremonies okay yes they did that but
the Aztecs weren't getting in ships and
going up and and and trying to invade
Europe or Africa why not
is it is it it is because they could
have but they decided not to because
they figured that be taking it too far
let's just because they didn't have the
interest they didn't have the ability
they didn't have the technology they
didn't have the the drive to do that
they didn't have the really the interest
in going and discovering other
far-reaching lands that's what stopped
them
the main focus for the Aztecs was they
felt they had to continue to offer blood
sacrifices to their gods and that was
the entire focus of their of their
civilization you had you had the right
in the middle of the Aztec capital you
had the the temple there and this was
literally the focus and so from their
perspective you know what why would they
get in ships and go somewhere else it's
just it's a matter of efficiency we're
gonna do all we just need to keep we
need to keep the gods satiated with more
blood more blood more blood more blood
to spend time and and treasure going off
of across an unknown sea to an unknown
destination there's no reason to do that
that would actually have interfered with
their ability to continue killing and
ripping out hearts and and and feeding
those sacrifices to their to their
imaginary gods so that's what stopped
them and you find similar situations and
other empires across the world so I feel
like if we're going to have these
conversations about the history of
slavery in the history of empire
building at some point maybe perhaps
especially in university systems maybe
we extend our we widen the lens a little
bit and realize that there's a whole
that there
that the world does not begin and end
with the United States there's a whole
great greater picture out there that we
could look at all right let's go to
emails Matt well show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com this is from
Aaron says huge fan of the show love the
way you you think even if we don't
always agree logic is important and it
seems less and less people use it and
it's what makes your podcast so
compelling that being said I'm
interested in your thoughts on the
simulation argument it's based only it's
based on only three paths humanity can
take one humanity is never able to
create a simulation to humanity has the
ability to create the simulation but for
some reason decides against it three
humanity creates a simulation and if
three is true the probability is that we
are in a simulation curious on your
thoughts if you don't know a lot about
the argue
you can listen to Joe Rogan and Nick
Bostrom discuss it on episodes 1350 but
I warn you part of this podcast is
painful because Rogan doesn't grasp it
thanks for your podcast well I'm not
sure that I grasp it either
so when you say simulation you mean that
we're all living in the matrix
essentially or that we're in a Sims game
and we're the Sims I'm familiar with
that hypothetical or thought experiment
I'm not familiar with the formal
argument that you've laid out there so
I'd have to look into it I guess here
are my general thoughts first of all
it's so important to distinguish and
this is a this is a a principle that I
think applies far beyond this particular
discussion it is so important to
distinguish between possibility and
probability and people rarely do this in
these kinds of discussions is it
possible that we're living in a virtual
world and we are all virtual girls
to paraphrase Madonna yes it's possible
I must say it's possible because it's
not logically impossible and anything
that isn't logically impossible is
therefore logically possible it's
possible that Superman exists it's
possible that there are large pink
dragons living on the moon it's possible
that a real nigerian prince will
actually email me tomorrow and really
offer me 20 million dollars i these
things are possible but is there any
compelling reason to think that they're
actually true well no it's definitely
possible that the pink dragons live on
the moon nobody can say that's
impossible is there any reason to think
they do no there's no evidence for it so
this is just a possibility that I've
conjured in my imagination and so it may
be possible but it's not remotely
probable or plausible now the simulation
idea yes it's possible no it's not
remotely probable and there's no
evidence for it there's no indications
pointing to it there's no particular
reason to believe that it's actually
true and I certainly don't buy the
premise that human technology is moving
inexorably towards this this
eventualities of building a simulation I
don't see why that hat white has to go
in that direction
have that result and even if it is and
there is a simulation built or there
will be I don't see how the simulated
beings would be conscious
how could you simulate a person simulate
them which means that there's no actual
person so how could you simulate a
person and then that simulated nonentity
begins to experience its own existence
in some way I mean you could sooner
convince me that we're all very lifelike
robots but with a simulation it means
that we're not flesh and blood at all
right so there how would we be conscious
and if that's possible then how do we
how do we know that video game
characters today aren't conscious maybe
Mario's been conscious this whole time
who knows but that makes no sense really
because simulated beings are not organic
they don't have brains they don't have
bodies and with any of the things that
seem to be necessary conditions for
consciousness at least in this world so
that's why I wouldn't be persuaded
although I mean I love the idea sort of
that maybe I'm neo so I kind of am
entertained by that but I can't say that
I'm convinced this is from Sean says hi
Matt somebody yesterday accused you of
trying to appease people and appeal to
the masses but I think that's the least
accurate possible way to describe you it
seems like you sometimes go out of your
way to piss off your own fence you're
basically the least pandering media
person I've ever seen I've it's almost
like you don't you don't want to be
liked I've noticed that when you get on
a subject that's turning your listeners
against you you'll then stay on it for
days just to prove a point it's weird
but I respect it keep doing you well I
appreciate that Sean I think if that was
a compliment though despite common
perception I actually don't try I don't
try to piss people off for the sake of
it and I don't really enjoy being
disliked I don't think anybody does I
like being liked who doesn't but I can't
help but lapse back into being myself I
guess and that's where I run into
trouble let's see okay here's here's one
I wanted to read this is from anonymous
says hi Matt subject line by the way is
Ken lying ever be ethical I
that lying is wrong and sinful
especially when you do it to the ones
you love but is it ever ethical I was
married to a physically and emotionally
abusive man for I'm not going to say the
number of years to protect in it
anonymity here one day a few years ago
after he slapped me across the face I
decided I had had enough
I left him that same day and never spoke
with him again except an email format
over the divorce dealings I don't find
out until later that I was pregnant with
his child I knew that I had to protect
my baby at all costs
I knew all too well that he was what he
was capable of and the bruises on my
body were still purple the mere thought
of him laying a hand on my baby enraged
me I vowed never to tell him so not to
risk my child safety and well-being I
immediately moved back to my home state
to be close to my family I was very
careful about social media because I
didn't want anything getting back to him
outside of my immediate family mom dad
and sisters I told everyone that I was
artificially inseminated my family
agreed that it would be best to tell
people that story said that the chances
of him finding out could be as minimal
as possible nine months later I had my
beautiful baby girl she's the light of
my life and the greatest blessing God
has ever given me
my sweet little girl is six now and has
never known the truth about her
conception she was three years old when
she was three years old my now husband
entered into our lives and he's been a
hair father ever since my father is my
husband is a loving caring father and
husband and I am so grateful that my
daughter gets to grow up in a normal
family I think I did the right thing and
not telling my ex about my daughter but
in doing so I've lied to everybody my
husband thinks the same thing that
everyone else thinks that I was
artificially inseminated I had to tell
him that story when I first met him
because I didn't know that yet if I
could trust him I also didn't feel like
I could tell my daughter the truth what
if she tries to contact him when she's a
teen when I fabricated this whole story
I initially decided to only tell my
daughter the truth when she's 18 that
way he won't be able to take her away
from me I know in my heart that I'm
doing this to protect my child but I
feel I feel really guilty still and I
find the thought of lying to my daughter
almost unbearable luckily she hasn't
asked me yet who her real father is but
I know she will someday is it wrong to
lie even when you're protecting someone
as a mother I would do anything to
protect my baby lie cheat steal if
necessary so why do I feel so damn too
guilty should I have handled this
differently
well that's quite a situation as I'm
sure you're aware now to answer the
question in the subject line can lying
ever be ethical I would say yes it can
be now when I read that subject line I
thought that this was going to go in
some hypothetical academic sort of
direction with the question and maybe
you'd have one of those the classic
hypothetical is would it be ethical to
lie to the Nazis if you're in Nazi
Germany and they're knocking on your
door and you're hiding Jews in the Attic
would it be ethical to lie to them and
tell them that no you're not I would say
of course it's an ethical the only other
option in that case would be to tell the
truth to save your own skin and of
cowardice thus sending those people to
their horrifying painful deaths clearly
to me that's not the ethical choice but
just because lying can be ethical
doesn't mean that every example of lying
ostensibly to protect somebody actually
is ethical and I have to say that to me
for my limited perspective as somebody
who doesn't know anything about you
other than what I just read I would say
that your case would definitely seem not
to be an example of ethical line I would
say this is very unethical lying now
leaving someone who's a danger to you
that of course makes sense
he has no right to treat you the way
that he did you had to leave to save
yourself from who knows what he might
have done next so I get that I think
anybody gets that nobody would have any
qualms with that and if they did who
cares because he had to do what was
right for you for your safety and it may
even be perfectly ethical to try and and
and keep him from having any kind of
extended contact or relationship with
your daughter if you have good reason to
think that he's a danger to her then
then yes that would be ethical too but
do you have the right to keep him from
from knowing the very fact that he has a
daughter no I would say no because
that's his daughter
like it or not even if he's a scumbag
that's still his daughter I think he has
a right at a minimum to know that she
exists
he did help to conceive her after all if
he's a dangerous man if he's an abuser
which he sounds like then it doesn't it
doesn't mean he has any right to be
involved in raising her but he does have
a right to know at least and putting
that aside your daughter definitely has
a right to know that that she has a
father and who he is that she wasn't
conceived in a petri dish
yeah you're right at this age she
probably isn't wondering about that or
doesn't understand anyway but eventually
she's gonna want to know and and I I
think she has a right to know and your
current husband even has a right to know
the truth so from my vantage point I
would say that the ethics of lying
really depend on whether the person
you're lying to has a right to know the
truth about are you keeping a truth from
someone that they have a right to now
the point with the Nazi example is that
the Nazi has no right to know whether
you're hiding a Jewish family in the
Attic or not they have no right to that
information and and there could be less
extreme examples where somebody is
demanding information they have no right
to it and maybe you feel like the only
way to keep that information they have
no right to in the first place from them
is to tell an untruth and I would say in
that case it's perfectly ethical because
they have no right to it right but in
this case there is information here
there's a truth that people in your life
have a right to you don't own that truth
your daughter has a right to know who
her father is her father has a right to
know that he that he has a daughter and
who she is your current husband has a
right to know I think as well and I
think you know all this which is why
your conscience is eating at you and
that's why you're emailing in the first
place don't take this as any kind of
harsh judgment understand that you may I
understand why you did what you did you
were seemingly in an impossible
situation you made a choice you know you
decided to tell a lie and this is this
is the the classic thing that everyone
everyone learns to some extent and
life at some point you you tell a big
lie and eventually you got to follow
that up with more lies more lies and
more lies there's no such thing as
telling one big lie it never happens
because you're gonna have to support
that lie with other lies and eventually
you've weaved this web of deception
where you're looking back at it and you
realize there is no way to justify this
this is obviously wrong and I would say
the same in your case now as far as as
far as what to do from here and how to
go about revealing the truth because I
don't think that you just run into the
living room at the drop of a hat and say
let me tell everybody I don't think it's
the way to handle it I think you have to
be thoughtful and considered and and
careful about how you reveal the truth
which I do think you should reveal but
how to go about that I you know I what I
would really recommend first and
foremost is that you seek the counsel of
not people in your immediate family and
not that their counsels are relevant
although I think they cancelled
cancelled you wrong six years ago but of
course you continue talking to them and
relying on the but but I think you need
to seek the counsel of somebody who
doesn't know you as well as they do is
it isn't so emotionally tied to you but
also knows you a lot better than I do
because I don't know you at all so you
know I don't know if you go if you go to
a church if there's a pastor you could
talk to just I would seek the counsel of
someone who knows you know you could sit
down with face to face but he isn't so
emotionally invested in it and talked to
them about how should you you know you
know that you're in the wrong it sounds
to me like you know you're in the wrong
where do you go from here how do you how
do you get yourself out of this and so I
would I would talk to somebody about
that but thank you for the question in
any case all right um one last question
this is from Luke says Matt Matt Matt
Matt
just for the record some of us some of
us do respect the office of president
regardless of who's sitting there even
though I'm a registered and voting
Republican I always made the point of
saying President Obama in conversation
during his time in office and never said
blatantly disrespectful things about him
in conversation regardless of how how I
felt about his policies side note I know
you won't read this on air
you only read stuff you argue you can
argue with and you won't be able to
argue with this so feel free to stop
reading at this point you coward
in short precursor you are my second
favorite person on the daily wire line
up right behind Ben you coward you're
the you're my second favorite person
so I normally agree with you I would say
85% of time we align but when we don't I
can respect and understand your
reasoning at least I could until now you
gave a few reasons as to why we would
have no reason not to respect the office
of a politician you gave a few reasons
as to why we would have no reason not to
respect the office of hold on a second I
got a I got to work through this
sentence you gave a few reasons as to
why we would have no reason not to
respect the office of a politician we
would have no reason not to respect so
we would have a reason to respect but I
was saying that we don't okay anyway I'm
all charged for it first
was that first was that it's not the
office of a monarch now you did not
explicitly say that one should respect a
monarch but it was heavily implied if
not for the simple reason that why else
would you even pose this as a reason
unless you imply that a monarch is to be
respected I wholly disagree monarch
monarch rule is imposed an elected
officials rule is subject to the people
respecting the office is respecting the
people's rule by proxy this is a great
reason to respect the office of the
president Luke 1 Matt zero secondly you
said that there are that they are our
employees now you're implying that
employees aren't to be respected I spent
five years working as a manager of a
retail pharmacy chain and I always
respected my employees and in return I
earned that respect I'm actually
surprised at your candor on the subject
considering the fact that your boss Ben
Shapiro almost outright says rare that
he respects his employees you among them
it should be a given that we should
respect our public official on the
ground on this ground alone Luke - Matt
zero next you said that you respect them
if they earn it and you don't if they
don't I think you're confusing respect
and agreement you can disagree with the
actions and words of a politician and
still respect the office or the
officials themselves I think that in
order to lose my respect a politician
would have to do something terribly
egregious on the other hand you're
making it sound like we should not start
out in a place of respect and make them
earn it and I wholly disagree with that
notion Luke 3 Matt zero
actually Matt negative one because
you're a disgusting human being now I
now I know you're going to think I'm
disrespecting you in this email but that
is exactly the childish thing you would
think you sniveling baby I'm only
disagreeing with you that's all I have
to say about that thanks for that email
Luke and I appreciate I appreciate it I
appreciate your candor but I'll have to
maintain my original position which is
and my first point with we say respect
the office my first question is what
what actually does that really mean I
understand it's a phrase it's a slogan
it's a nice thing to say but on a day to
day basis what do you mean respect the
oven how do you respect an office
abstractly in the in the absence Hedy I
understand how to respect a person okay
I don't really understand how to respect
in abstract office so you don't have to
explain what that means exactly so I'm
not sure I get it
secondly I go back to what I said that
with politicians I think in America one
of the things that sets us apart or
should set us apart from other places in
the world from almost every other place
in the world is that we do not certainly
not worship we don't adore our
politicians we we are very skeptical of
them we're very open
I guess what I'm saying this is how it
should be because especially in recent
times it hasn't actually been this way
that's a problem but way it should be
the way the system was originally set up
is that we were skeptical
we are critical we're not supposed to
fall into cults of personality with our
politicians we look at them they are our
employees and we say do your job if you
don't do it we're gonna fire you and you
know we're not going to bow down before
you you if you want us to respect you
you gotta you have to earn it that's my
essential point politicians should earn
our respect and if there is a politician
who is is
not respectable because they're corrupt
and they're a liar and they're not doing
their jobs they're not representing the
interests of the people okay even it's
not the present let's say it's a
congressman and there are plenty of
congressmen out there like this and
congresswomen so this is if this were
let's say a contemptible human being and
a liar and a phony and a fraud and an
opportunist I have no respect for them
but I respect their office what how do
you even delineate that in your mind and
what does that mean in practice I just
don't think it means anything
I think it's a very simple concept earn
my respect do I go in immediately not
respecting politicians no I'm sort of
neutral I have no feelings about them
show me show me what you can do prove it
that's my that's my approach this is why
I've so often said we shouldn't be fans
of politicians any politician we could
be supporters but our support should be
very conditional and very tentative we
in sports we don't like Fairweather fans
I get that but in in with politics we
shouldn't be fans at all but we should
be Fairweather supporters as in I'm
supporting you now because I you know I
I to some extent I believe that you have
the character for the job that you have
the integrity for the job I support your
policies and so I support you but if
it's revealed that you have bad
character and if it's review if you
don't follow through and your promises
in terms of policies then then that's
gone I don't support you anymore
why would I what am i supporting no I
never supported you because I love your
smile I supported you for what you were
gonna bring to the table if you don't
bring that to the table like you
promised then I'm gonna kick you out of
the dinner party that's the way it
should go
so unfortunately Luke I still think you
lose this conversation well thanks again
for the email and I think so I guess
we'll leave that there for the for the
weekend have a great weekend everybody I
remind you again that my book Church of
cowards has gone on
al pre-sale comes out February 25th but
please go on Amazon and and in pre-order
pre-order one for yourself and your
friends for your whole church you know I
won't stop you from doing that and look
out for that on February 25th alright
that's it
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there